speaking of good signs a very
bad situation for an alaska
uh state senator is that alaska airlines
has banned her from flying on alaska
airlines i'm talking here about
state senator laura reinbold
tim thompson spokesman for alaska
airlines told the anchorage daily news
over the weekend quote
we have notified senator laura reinbold
that she is not permitted to fly with us
for her continued refusal to comply
with employee instruction regarding the
current mask
policy apparently she has not only been
refusing to wear a mask she was even
recorded arguing at juno international
airport
arguing with an alaska airlines staff
member about
mask policy and the video appears to
show airline staff telling her
the mask must be on it must cover your
mouth
it must also cover your nose like the
basics we're going back to march 2020
on masking and she had been apparently
asking about a mask
exemption with upright employees with
uptight
employees at the counter she said i was
reasonable with all alaska airlines
employees
and that she did ultimately board the
flight but she's been vocally opposed to
any covet 19 mitigation measures
she is objected to the alaska airlines
mass policy that was enacted before the
federal government enacted a mass policy
alaska airlines
had already been saying even before
biden came in you have to wear a mask
she's been calling
alaska airlines staff mask bullies
and when she was asked by
flight attendants when boarding the
flight to put the mask on
i guess she went nuts and then uh has
sent some kind of apology to the staff
it's all completely crazy
and this is the only airline she can
take
to go from uh between anchorage and juno
unless she starts flying private or like
could she connect somewhere in the
mainland
imagine having to fly from juneau to
like seattle
and then seattle to anchorage because
she's banned
actually even that flight i think is
only in alaska
i don't know what the hell she's going
to do quite frankly
because if you're an alaska state
senator needing to regularly get
back and forth to anchorage there aren't
really other options
other than alaska airlines and you know
i know a lot of people in the audience
have dealt with the mask
stuff when flying but you don't
necessarily expect it
from a sitting state senator even on my
flight i talked about this on my i flew
a different not alaska airlines which
as far as i know alaska airlines is
being really good on the mask stuff
not every airline is i flew a different
airline to aruba
last month fully vaccinated of course
and with a mask and everything
and um there was absolutely no
enforcement of masking there were a lot
of people
sitting near me who were playing sort of
koi
with the food and drink policy where
even though the airline announced
multiple times
if you were actively eating or drinking
you can take your mask off
if you are between sips or bites
put the mask on and there were a bunch
of people on the plane who were doing
the thing where
they take the mask off and they hold
their drink up
so they appear to be in the process of
actively
drinking and then they just watch a
two-hour movie on the tv screen
and just hold the drink there was no
enforcement whatsoever
at one point i saw a woman get up from
her seat and go to the bathroom
walk by flight attendants with just no
mask and then walk back to her seat
and uh i'd say half of the people near
me the mask wasn't even covering the
nose and
you know as i said i wouldn't have
traveled if i weren't vaccinated so
i wasn't bothered in that i was you know
hiding thinking i'm going to get sick
you needed a negative to everybody on
the plane needed a negative test
in order to board and i was vaccinated i
it wasn't because of that but if the
rules are right now to fly you wear the
mask i'm going to play the game if i
don't want to
wear the mask on the plane i'll just say
i'm not going to travel for the time
being
because i wanted to travel i wore the
mask whatever i think about my personal
level of risk
that i think is what's frustrating which
is you know the rules when you get on
you're told when you book the flight
you're told when you check in for the
flight
you're not even allowed near the gate
without a mask you're told via
announcements
and then for laura reinbold to just
continue arguing about this
you don't have to fly now you might say
well she does have to fly
she has to get back and forth from
anchorage to juno because she's a state
senator well okay
she could look at driving she could look
at chartering a plane she doesn't have
to fly on alaska airlines
nor does she have a right to fly on
alaska airlines and she is now banned
from alaska airlines no word on how she
will commute
for her work as an alaska state senator
it's not going to be that much longer
guys if you're supposed to wear the mask
just wear the mask